Nik Spencer's new run on spider-man has
finally reached ten issues plus an
annual which is actually the second
annual this year because Marvel thinks
we have no attention span regardless I
think it's a good amount of time to
really get a feel for how he handles the
character and what he'll do with it in
the future
I think it's important to get past the
initial story arc to really know what a
run will be like for example chips at
our skis run on spectacular spider-man
was pretty boring for the first few
issues he felt like a superhero Seinfeld
with no stakes but then he found his
footing and kicked it into high gear
with arguably one of the best spider-man
runs the past 20 years
Nick Spencer is already wrapping up a
third storyline and I finally collected
enough of my thoughts to talk about it
primarily that I have a crazy conspiracy
theory about it I think this book is
written almost entirely from an angle of
criticizing modern spider-man comics
that came before it while I was
initially a little worried about him
getting handed the title after the Hydra
cap Fiasco last year I think Nick has
come around to making something really
great this book feels like spider-man
again because he understands the
character a little better than Dan Slott
did you know the guy who wrote the book
for the past 10 years and like I said I
think the most interesting part about
this book happens to be the not so
subtle differences between Spencer's
Peter Parker and slots Peter Parker
which is kind of what the whole first
arc is about despite the two of them
aligning pretty much the same
politically in being friends behind the
scenes I can't help but notice how much
of the subtext this book seems to be
taking potshots at slots writing over
the years
Nick Spencer is amazing spider-man book
he constructs and heavily criticizes Dan
slots amazing spider-man book and given
slots less than stellar relationship
with the fans that does a lot to get
longtime Spidey readers back into the
book it's essentially saying that the
weird direction the book has been going
for 10 years is over and that Spencer is
going to bring back a more traditional
version of Peter Parker that's closer to
what we had before yeah but in order for
my analysis of Spencer's book to make
sense I better give some context
regarding why the book is so out of line
with slots vision Dan Slott isn't an
inherently bad writer in fact I've loved
a couple of his stories but he's made a
lot of decisions to deliberately piss
off fans of the book because he has this
mantra it's good to show
contempt for your audience that's
Michael Bay he was never afraid to
challenge the status quo of a spider-man
or try new things but the irritation
with Spidey fans came from his decisions
usually having no lasting effect or
trampling on established and consistent
ideas to fit his own here's a few
examples he does something like superior
spider-man which gives a long Redemption
arc for Doc Ock then he dies heroically
to bring Peter back good stuff and then
shortly after that brings it back again
as a villain and then he asked to start
the redemption arc over again he
introduces a new love interest for Peter
in Carli Cooper but she gets passed
around between so many writers that her
personality is never fully established
and readers just can't get interested in
him then when he takes over as the
full-time writer of the book and has the
opportunity to correct that he pretty
much just gets rid of her as a love
interest and forget she exists he also
completely rewire his black cat's
character and turns her into a heartless
murdering villain even though it's
extremely out of her character and then
the big one
Parker Industries is an interesting idea
but it goes against a lot of core
character traits of spider-man and makes
him unrelatable for about 30 issues and
then he just writes it all away like it
never happened
Hellen one more day Parker Industries is
cited as a proverbial bad end for Peters
life where he just becomes lonely and
self-destructive
I think this leads into the biggest
point of contention between slot and
fans about Peters characterization Dan
Slott hates Peter Parker he thinks Peter
Parker is his own worst enemy and
incredibly self-destructive and toxic to
the people around him that that's not
spider-man sure that could maybe fit
daredevil and it especially works for
Iron Man but never Spidey Peter Parker
is a victim of fate the majority of the
time he was relatable because his
problems were usually out of his control
and he felt like the world was shooting
on him all the time because he made one
mistake it wasn't just a constant stream
of selfish actions compounding on each
other and damaging his relationships
[ __ ] pretty much writes Peter Parker to
piss off and alienate everyone around
him and constantly end up being a loser
because he was incompetent and selfish
he makes Peter Parker a jerk with no
regard for others he makes Peter Parker
irresponsible
let's run it down Peter takes credit for
all the accomplishments Ock made in his
body and capitalizes on it to start his
own company and make money
Peter buys the Baxter building and when
Johnny is angry about it he chooses to
fight him and endanger people instead of
just explaining himself because slot
wanted an action scene in the issue
Peter gets jealous of Iron Man and tries
to beat the [ __ ] out of him in a public
place
Peter lets Harry handle all of the
fallout of the company tanking and bails
on him because he doesn't feel like
helping and then justifies it to himself
Peter continuously tries to murder the
Venom symbiote after knowing full well
that it's a living and sentient creature
Peter fights Johnny Storm again and then
lets the super villain escape because he
was nice enough to help keep the
building from tumbling after their fight
even though letting criminals get away
leads to very bad things making Peter
and inconsiderate [ __ ] as where Dan
Slott spider-man fails and why it ends
up pushing so many fans away that's not
relatable and that's not a role model
sure he was never perfect he made some
pretty big mistakes before but Peter
Parker was never an inherently selfish
guy nor did he choose to act solely for
his benefit at the cost of others and
after 10 long years of frustration from
Dan and his readers he finally leaves
the book with a lackluster character
death in a generic one-shot issue we've
seen a million times before this sets
the stage for Nick Spencer to come back
in and pick up the pieces and he starts
right away with a choice that caught my
eye
bringing back Randy Robertson as Peters
roommate and friend not a lot of people
remember it but there was a time in the
90s where MJ was kidnapped by a
supervillain who faked her death
Peter was all distraught and lonely with
nowhere to live so Randy took him in as
his roommate and became his best friend
you know since Harry was dead at this
point
Randy and Peter shared financial
struggles with a smile and went out on
the town a party and cheer up Peter
about MJ's quote-unquote death then
after MJ came back Randy kind of faded
back into obscurity in the books and had
only random guest appearances now and
then I really liked their interaction
back in those days and I was sad to see
that dissolve so quickly it's cool to
see Spencer bring that back and it also
serves as a sort of rejection of
something slot did a few years prior in
Big Time spider-man I think this has to
be the most clear-cut example of the way
slot wrote his stories for spider-man I
present to you the Kevin the mouldy
piece of cheese paradox during the very
beginning of the big time arc Peter ends
up evicted for the billionth time and
needs another roommate so his first
resort is to call Randy Randy then gives
him the cold shoulder and acts like he's
a huge prick and he can't stand him
slot even goes so far as to write in a
super deep cut reference to some random
joke from like 17 years earlier in the
book where Peter keeps an old piece of
cheese in the fridge and names at Kevin
back then Randy just kind of jokingly
blew it off and started asking Peter if
he would come hang out for that night he
felt like Peter was becoming too closed
off and he needed to get out more he was
genuinely worried about his mental
well-being but in slots' book randy
tells him to go [ __ ] himself and hangs
up why because then it would impede on
the direction of the book that slot
wanted to go so that means he has a
strong familiarity of this story and
these characters to make references like
this and he knew Randy would be the most
logical option but he changed the
character's personality to allow for the
story he wanted to tell he changes the
characters to fit the story instead of
the other way around it's something so
minor but I think this is fundamentally
the most straightforward case of why
slots writing is so subject to criticism
he knows how things should be but he
doesn't care and he changes it anyway
because he thinks his idea is better
than the sensible thing so he writes all
kinds of character interactions that
don't feel true to these characters and
then we get this preview issue from
Spencer where Randy is back to being
Peters friend but then Peter lets a
criminal get away for a really flimsy
justification and as a reader I was
immediately worrying that we'd be back
to the same old [ __ ] of him doing the
wrong thing constantly but then an issue
1 Peter acknowledges that it was out of
character to do that and he feels bad
about it then shortly after it's
revealed to the world that Peter got all
of his degrees in science by
plagiarizing the work of Otto Octavius
kind of this means that Peter loses his
job and is punished for being
irresponsible and then Spencer does
something kind of interesting he starts
finally pointing out how weird and ahead
of character Peter has been for the past
few years he goes so far as to compare
actions like taking credit for Otto's
work to letting Uncle Ben's killer
escape
that's extreme but like I understand the
sentiment now I know the obvious example
of Spencer spider-man being a return to
form is him getting back together with
MJ which feels really long overdue but
again he frames the scene of them
getting back together almost identical
to something slot did a few months prior
but has a totally different outcome this
all builds up to the focal point of the
first arc spider-man and Peter Parker
becoming two different people during a
random sci-fi accident Peter and Spidey
becomes split into two different guys
divvying up their personality traits
equally among the two of them one could
assume at the start of this that Spencer
is going for like a brains versus brawn
sort of thing like how Clark Kent had to
outsmart Superman in that one movie but
then were given a curveball and learning
that the Spidey half is still a science
whiz and now Peter's intelligence is
that of an average 30-something jobless
burnout that's when I figured Spencer
was going for something a little
unconventional he split Peter Parker
into two halves the character we all
know and love who just wants to be
responsible and a not so exaggerated
caricature of modern spider-man I was
racking my brain over it for days but I
figured it out this is that obnoxious
selfish douchebag that we've been
reading for the past 10 years it all
checks out so this version of Spidey is
devoid of responsibilities but he's not
an idiot
he's opportunistic and uses his
intelligence to take selfish things he
steals himself a super robot to trash
the city and stop crime in half the time
he also tries to bank on his own super
powers by selling himself as an uber
service
his sense of humor goes way overboard
from quips into just being half-baked
and he'll placed references and he does
whatever he can to screw over Peter
Parker and ignore his existence major
plot point of slots final arc on the
book was that he was spending more time
as spider-man than his Peter Parker
because he had done so much to wreck
Peter Parker's life and it was easier to
just ignore all the consequences this is
echoed in house lot Spidey doesn't pay
Peter any attention and dismisses him as
a born loser Spencer takes every
negative and annoying trope from the
other run and turns it into a character
that fully expresses what was so wrong
with the book for ten years
in fact he turns this take on
biting into an antagonist for Peter
Peter doesn't beat him by just being
smarter in fact he takes advantages of
slots by T's negligence and defeats him
in a really simple way that even an
idiot could have pulled off
Peter ultimately triumphs because
responsibility is the most powerful
trait between the two of them even
though the other guy has the brains the
jokes and all the powers he wasn't
really spider-man because spider-man is
about doing the right thing even when it
puts you in a world of hurt not doing
the wrong thing to avoid being hurt now
feel free to call me a loony and Sam
cloud watching to create a subtext that
isn't there leaving my negative feelings
toward the previous writing in the book
has made me biased and I want to
interpret miscellaneous things as jabs
but I think you have to admit that maybe
my theory holds some weight in a few
places beyond all this possible
criticism of his predecessor I think
Spencer just nails a lot of the smaller
nuances of the character his Peter
Parker has a better sense of humor
that's less reliant on instantly dated
pop-culture references he's also better
making Spidey feel like an underdog who
wins by outsmarting the bad guy rather
than out smashing him I also really
enjoy the way he tied this book into his
first Spidey related endeavor superior
foes of spider-man is a really quirky
and fun series that lets you get to know
some of Spidey's low-level baddies a
little better it shows they're a lot
like him in a way just loveable losers
with powers trying to get by so the
decision to have boomerang becomes
Spidey's friend and started learning
some responsibilities from him is really
cool actually
hopefully they bury the hatchet about
that hole stop hitting yourself thing he
did a few years back the most recent arc
also has black cats character restored
to pretty much where she was prior to
one more day Peters friend and superhero
confidant who keeps a secret and teams
up with him when he needs the backup the
most these last few years a lot of other
writers have been using her as a
murderous crime boss who wants to kill
spider-man and needless to say it was
pretty out of character in all three of
his story arcs so far Spencer has given
fans something get excited about
letting two people just love each other
again brief reunion of a short-lived and
much-loved team and a long lasting
friendship restore I'm definitely
interested to see what he does with this
new villain he's working on and there's
a lot of speculation that he's even
planning to fully undo one more day
which we've been getting a decent number
of hints at recently from other creators
but nothing concrete God they just keep
throwing it in our face don't they
speaking of throwing things in your face
hey did you know that I have a discord I
have to give props to the art on the new
run Ryan Hawley is a great choice and I
really love the way he frames action
scenes I'm a sucker for the blocky
sharp-edged art style he does because it
reminds me of guys like Bruce Timm John
Romita Jr and Mike Minneola if I had any
complaints it's that he draws Peter and
MJ really similar to mark and Eve from
his other noteworthy book which allows
me to make horrible edits like this one
and he'll even though Humberto Ramos
isn't my favorite artist I really like
how the book looked in the Thieves Guild
arc feels like he's really trying to
tighten up his Anatomy and perspectives
and I think it's some of his best work
Nick Spencer's book is succeeding and
winning over fans right now after they
felt alienated and left the wayside for
about a decade and it's not because he's
just pandering and throwing in
fanservice if that was his goal his
stories would have a lot more of this
stuff no the reason fans are finally
backing this book with a smile again is
because he's writing something that
feels true to the characters Peter
Parker is finally acting like himself
again like an imperfect guy who still
tries his best and puts others before
himself that's the guy that's always
been my role model
feels like the triumphant return of
someone we lost a long time ago and
while we've gotten used to a pale
imitation nothing beats the original
Dick Spencer gave us our hero back and I
can't thank him enough
[Music]
Happy Holidays missing a merry Kwanzaa
limited run Christmas merch is now
available in the store with designs by
my good buddy Joey the holiday theme
designs are still in stock and they'll
be gone about midway through January so
pick them up before they disappear until
next year please consider buying some of
the merch it really helps me out the
link is in the description
[Music]
[Music]